be willing to negotiate everything  except for your values I used to think  of negotiating as a zero-sum game and  it's not at all you can find a way where  both parties get better than they were  before which is the entire point that is  how a negotiating works if you're doing  it well I didn't understand that I  thought everything was an arm wrestle I  thought everything was like this for  that no give I was ruthless with vendors  but then I realized that this long term  doesn't create good relationships and  they will not be loyal to you at all  which long term has a more negative  impact than giving them the extra 10 I  negotiated everything including my  values because I was doing business in a  way that was contrary to the values that  I wanted to embody it's balancing both  your need today your need in 10 years  and their need today and their need in  10 years I found my middle ground of